are stepping into a portal taking us
into another dimension called particle
ink to guide us on this journey we have
a very special guest I want to introduce
story to the show Welcome story what
time is it is it the evening it's 306 in
the afternoon very late last night doing
what I have some sock puppet friends we
were getting into people's drawers hey
come on
thank you it took me like a milliseconds
to get shot it's fine that was funny
story okay now what should people expect
you know when they're walking through
this this portal this realm that you're
that you're introducing us to well
particle ink speed of dark is an
immersive walk through experience you
are correct we have incredible augmented
reality installations of art that will
blow your mind pop-up performances and
of course compelling storytelling done
by Yours Truly the interstellar
Storyteller also known the story and uh
you know we play
every night except two nights a week we
don't play on Tuesdays or Wednesday so
Thursday through Monday seven and nine
PM downtown Monday is just at seven okay
now why is the arts district the perfect
place for particle ink because they
allow people like me there
there's a lot of different characters in
ours because it is the burgeoning
creativity of Las Vegas this is not a
commercial spectacle with uh you know
people flipping off of high diving
trampolines into the water this is
heartfelt entertainment for the whole
family now I what I know I know that
it's a little it's kind of dark and
scary a little bit too right to walk
through there it depends on your
perception my friend this is what I'm
looking at is kind of scary me I don't
know well it's got to be dark because
we've got state of the art projection
mapping but this is for your whole
family okay we have children of all ages
that come through and they love it if
your kids are creative if they love
entertainment if you want them to expand
their minds this is the perfect place
for them now story speaking of expanding
the mind you know is there some wisdom I
feel like you've been through a lot
you've seen a lot of things give us some
advice I've been to every Dimension many
many times right and my advice is never
go outside barefoot anywhere okay I I
don't have feet anymore that's my one
piece of advice always wear feet
coverings you don't know what you're
going to step on okay okay okay come see
our show that's my biggest piece of
advice number one number one priority is
their website where do we get tickets
particleinc.com and we're only playing
to December 4th we have extended our
limited engagement with my popular
demand so many times like 10 honestly I
think five to ten times we've extended
our tickets oh wow but we are finally
closing and that may be some future
future plans but we we for now you must
come okay your last chance to go into
the realm welcome to you
always